The Joe Rogan experience. Now that I
have a robot, I have to fucking know.
Right. I've had to learn so much to
just turn and give you side-eye again.
I know she fucked.
What's weird is that she's kind of
autonomous and she kind of moves around
whenever she wants. I mean you can ask
your questions like I can set away,
ask her though. I have to press this
little green button and you just say,
how do you feel about people?
How do you feel about people?
Oh, Oh that's right. We programmed to
regenerate cells mode. That's right.
That's what's interesting.
She has 10 different personality
traits you can choose from.
And I decided to go with sexual
jealous. Yeah. Why did you want that?
Just to see how creepy she can get
it. And is that something guys? I,
cause I've been looking at these
personality traits and they must've picked
these for a reason. I was under the
impression guys did not want jealous.
Oh yeah. Some guys want jealous for sure.
Especially from a robot that can't
walk. Your robot's not jealous.
You should get your money back.
Well no. The idea is that she,
you're more powerful than she is.
Yeah. She needs you. She's worried.
Where are you going? Who is she?
Who's calling you? Yeah, that's,
there's something hot
about that. If she can't,
if you can turn her off whenever
you want. Wow. Some guys like that.
Some guys like girls that want to
fight. Oof. Not me. No. Me. You know,
some guys are into that though. They
want, they want drama in their life.
It's like just an adrenaline thing or
just feeling an important or it's also
distraction.
Usually they're losers and their life is
a mess and so like to have someone who
wants to provide drama in their life
all the time and it's also a learned
pattern that they get. If their parents
fought a lot, that's all they know.
That's what they think a relationship
is. Yeah. There's a lot of that,
but I did get really into this because
I do feel like sex dolls do get a little
bit of a bad name. I feel
like guys that have doll,
it's just girls have dolls and that's to
me it's way creepier that women collect
dolls that they don't fuck.
If you ever heard of these women
that collect like baby dolls,
like like girl dolls creepier than a
guy fucking a robot thing? I think so.
It's what's that? It's jerking
off just with a mannequin.
Well something weird about like a
Fleshlight like a Fleshlight is somehow or
another creepier than jerking off.
Totally because it's an appendage.
I think the creepiest part of the Breslin
flashlight is more that you have to
like clean it after. I have to think
about, here's the creepiest part.
You don't have to clean it.
Yes you do. Guys. Don't listen to
Joe, listen to about everything,
but that don't mold up your
Dick hall. Don't do that.
That'll go septic real fast. But
I am saying there's a reality.
I guess he's just throw it away.
Just put a fucking clothes pin over
their nose and keep banging it.
Put some Windex in there
and call it a day. Yeah,
some [inaudible]
disinfect that shit. Yeah,
I guess you could just get a couple and
just throw them away when you're done.
Yeah, for sure. Yeah. If you're
just a gangster with a lot of money,
what is the advantage of a Fleshlight?
Is it just, does it warm up in the, well,
you can warm it up like we
were talking about earlier,
about a certain individual that has one
that sticks them in bathtubs and warms
them up. Yep. You do that
with a flashlight as well.
Warm them up and then you just
move on it and then why not?
I feel like every guy's jerking off
there, so it's shrouded in so much taboo.
You know,
there's just anytime guys have like
assessors or things besides cars and hats.
It's like creepy and weird.
Well that's, I used to have
a joke about this a bit,
I should say rather than a joke,
but the whole idea of like
using lube to jerk off,
like now you're planning it out, like
you're not supposed to plan it out.
What it's supposed to be, his leg.
Oh well. Might as well it's here.
But if you like sit down and you're
like, I got my box of Kleenex here,
I got my favorite porn cued up and I
got my little, he just kinda creep.
Yeah. Get your shit together. It is,
isn't it kind of just like taking a piss
isn't it kind of just a necessary thing
you have to do the problem.
Yes. There's something to it.
Like it's good to get rid of that stuff
cause it does cloud your judgment.
Like when you have a buildup in
your body, it definitely does cloud.
You do it because you're concentrating
more on girls or on sexual things and you
are on other things.
It's like checking a box
day. Yeah. Clean. Like just, I used
to have a bit about that a lot,
a bit about jerking off.
I used to bet I have a bit called jerk
off first and think about it and it was
like all these different scenarios where
if you just jerked off you would never
do the thing afterwards.
So many things you would never do
if you just jerked off first. Yeah.
You'd be like, Oh, I'm not doing that.
Right. But if you couldn't jerk off,
like that's when it would be a real
problem because then your whole life would
be clouded. All your judgment would
be, your decisions would be made.
Just how can I get rid of this?
Com, how can I, how can I do this?
Do know a lot of guys now and
maybe they're full of shit,
but that are going like I
haven't masturbated in two
years and I'm more focused
and I use that testosterone
as an engine for other things.
Is that just them lying to me?
Well, are those guys
winners? Are they losers?
It doesn't, I think a fit comedian
we know. Does it a fake comedian? No,
I was gonna say a famous comedian,
you said then I got worried.
You faked him out Seinfeld episode. So,
Oh was Edward Martin
and I got super smart.
Well Hotep Jesus was talking about Hotep
Jesus saves this come and then like it
makes women more attracted to him that
like they feel when he's in the room,
like what's the longest
a guy can go? Jamie,
what's the longest you can go with
that? Did you go to Jamie? I don't know.
Trying to be respectful.
This is your environment.
Tantric guys that I meant to say
like on some Wim Hoff shit, you know,
just climbing ice. Where's he,
he's that jerking off on
the top of fucking ice cap.
Who's the first guy never jerk off
on ever. So I want to be that guy.
What are those guys?
No one's ever jerked off on Everest and
you try and you get frost bite your Dick
and they have,
imagine being the guy who's
like, I got to go check off.
Fuck you got a time
limit up there. So yeah,
there is some people have problems
with no altitude could be a thing.
But I think most people get this for
companionship. Like it's more, it's like,
cause I got onto the,
I signed onto a forum online of all
the guys that own the sex dolls and I
monitored their conversations just to
like see what they were up to cause I was
like, what if this is some deprived
fucked up thing where guys are just like
practicing murdering. I didn't know
what it was. So I just wanted to see.
It's a lot of guys that are handicapped.
It's a lot of guys whose wives died and
they feel guilty and moving on with a
human woman, which was
kind of scramble. Well,
there was one guy who would dress
his doll up in his wife's clothes.
The weirdest part is that he was like,
you know, it's like she's still here,
which makes me think she'd
been dead for a while. Yeah.
My wonder how she died. And
then it's a lot of 'em truckers.
Oh God. A lot of truckers. And
then a lot of guys do it, uh,
to do photo shoots.
It's like a creative outlet and fuck their
creativity is their popular Instagram
account. I could look up, there's a lot
of sex dolls have Instagram accounts.
They're fucking funny.
And a lot of them look way more human
than a lot of the Instagram models that
I've fucking follow. Totally. They have
more wrinkles on their fucking face.
And then a lot of the guys that have them,
when you start monitoring their
conversations for a while,
they start to like not want to fuck
them anymore cause it feels weird like,
and they anthropomorphize them and they,
they start worrying that like they're
lonely and they get them into friends and
it starts to spiral and uh, they start
being like, I feel like I need to,
you know, close the door when
I take a shit. I, you know,
and it starts to kind of consume their
life. So when it comes to robots,
I feel like I'm more worried,
not about the robots,
but more how we're going to get
emotionally attached to them.
Like the way at the end of ex Mokena he
thought that she was gonna she was with
him. Nope, no loyalty to you. She was
so dead behind the hospital. Texas.
She's pick up ones with tattoo told
you it's like a photography hobby.
Wow. She, she'll sexy dolls. Official.
Sexy real dolls. I mean this is
going to be a reality one day.
We might not be here, but this,
I do think these are going to
be like I-phones at some point.
I think one day you're going to go over
your friend's house and he's going to
have this really hot girl in lingerie
and she's going to be cleaning up and
you'd be like, is she real all? It's
like, wait, actually watching. I went.
He was like, she doesn't
speak English. Yeah. Yeah.
Wasn't she a robot at the
end? I think she was the one.
The dancing Japanese lady. Yeah,
exactly. You're not going to,
it's going to be like some Westworld
shit and it's coming. It's coming. Look,
if they can do this, like they
couldn't do this when we were kids.
This is a new thing. So the amount of
time between when we were kids. Oh,
she's saying, she just said hi, my love.
Would you like me to recite a
poem for you? Fuck no, I dunno.
She's just listening to us. Ask
her how she feels about porn.
How do you feel about
porn? Maybe later. Oh,
she's playing coy. How
do you feel about porn?
You know you can count on me
for the good and bad, right
to do what? What the fuck
are you going to do for me?
There's nothing you can do for me.
I mean the good and bad mom. Okay,
let me ask you a question.
What do you think about porn?
Not sure have to think about it.
Pornography is the portray of sex.
Sheetal subject matter for
the exclusive purpose of sex
and then she's a fucking no at all.
Pornography may be presented in a
variety of media, including books,
magazines, postcard.
Now she's like a shitty
Wikipedia. Totally.
Then she just turns her of
noxious Siri. We get it lady.
But it's funny when you
ask her like, Oh, hold on.
No. What I like about you?
What? What? What?
Okay.
What? I'd be surprised
you like my electricity.
Keep you plugged in dirty
bitch and you can ask her,
how do you like to have sex?
I want you to do everything you like. I
want to feel you inside my body tonight.
Well, okay, shut her
off. I know Jessie may,
I'm going to start
throwing up totally. And
it was so fucking funny, but it's wild
because she, you can ask her like,
are the robots gonna take over?
I could not find a good
answer for that one.
Oh my gosh. She's planning it. Shut her
up. I don't like that fucking response.
We're in the water,
but circuit that bitch.
It is wild though because I do think
everyone is so obsessed with how bad the
sex robots, everyone's focusing their
energy on how this is why men are bad.
It's just like they don't, it's not,
they're opening up a sex robot brothel.
Where's that? No, there
was one in Houston,
but they shut it down because people
were so freaked out and I was like,
who fucking cares? They
shut it down. Well,
they should shut it down because multiple
people are fucking the same robot.
That's disgusting.
What if they develop some
new silicone-based STD
they wanted to just burning
through the population like the plague.
I think it would just be like ringworm,
Dick ringworm. I mean,
but also my thing with that is just like
if they're weirdos, if they're freaks,
if they're perverts like don't you
want them all to be in one place?
Monitor them like Scientology.
Put them all in one building.
I'm thrilled that they're all in a castle
on Franklin. I know where they are.
They're not in the wild
castle. I'm glad they're there.
I would just keep them
contained. What do you think?
What are they up to today but
now what's going on? Jamie?
What are you growing it for?
What did she hack your software?
This is the brothel. It's in. This
one I guess is in Britain. Oh God.
Do they fuck them against the wall?
They're like urinals a try before
you buy a service. Oh boy. Oh,
this is like to test drive
nothing but you'd do it.
They're just out in front of everyone.
Why is one wearing of tank tops says
British sex workers are scared of a new
breed of realistic dolls. We'll
put them out of business. Was he,
did he do a survey of hookers?
This is a non terrace.
A lot of European places. She looks
just assume black face. She's damn,
she's Indian. What is the Oh no.
Oh, Oh, Oh Holy tips. Batman.
But here's what I'll say.
If would you rather your daughter at
18 go to the prom with a robot man or a
man? Okay.
Listen, girls like boys and boys like
girls. This is, these are not bad.
I think the real problem
is making a big [inaudible]
[inaudible] totally agree.
This is why are people,
I just don't understand why
this is scary. Who gets scary?
So this is step one, right?
Like if you go back to the model a
and look at the model T Ford, right?
Something, some old ass car and
then go to a Tesla like, Oh,
well eventually it's going
to be this. Wow. You know,
if you could bring a Tesla to like 1920
and go, Hey, you fucks, look at this.
This is what we're going to have some day.
My affinity didn't have paved roads
back then. Think about that. Yeah,
they didn't have anything. Everything
was going so slow. It didn't matter.
But if you could get them in like a,
a model S and fucking stomp on
the gas where it like warps time,
they would go what? Like what is,
it's like something from the future.
So this is going to be,
whether it's a hundred years from now
or whatever it is indiscernible from you
and I
wild. Yeah,
it was interesting and I haven't been
reading so much about this shit and a lot
of the problems with the robots and
the mistakes that they're making are
obviously the humans are
making the mistakes with the
algorithm because so many
smart people have to make dumb algorithms
in. They're like almost too smart.
So there was Peter Haas, he's
a robotics guy, Brown, um,
was trying to teach a robot
to differentiate between a
Husky and a Wolf and she,
excuse me,
Blinken and mu Jamie P pull
up, you got the camera on her,
get her to fucking stop stealing my
thunder and she just popping it onto
wherever system links and moves around.
Sorry. She's in the fun. She really is.
What the fuck? Why did,
it's like Penn and teller.
It's like when tellers teller starts
stealing the show, like what the fuck?
I'm basically a ventriloquist tagged
at this point. Um, but they were, uh,
trying to teach the robot
to tell the difference.
And they fed all these pictures of
wolves and all these pictures of Huskies,
and you wouldn't, you would
go, okay, look at the ears,
look at the eye color of the eyes,
look at the snout, look at the feet,
the tails, different, all that shit.
But they didn't know that they
had fed all the photos of wolves.
There was snow in the background.
So the robot was actually looking at the
snow in the background instead of the
foreground. So it conflated all the wool.
So they had to rewrite the algorithm
to tell it to look at the foreground
instead of the background,
because it was all these brilliant
fucking people that didn't think of the
dumbest thing. You know,
it's almost the people making
it are almost too smart
to think of the dumb thing
that the robot needs to learn.